Today, I'm going to be speaking with Mark
Robert Rank, who is professor of social welfare
at Washington University in St. Louis and
also author of the book Poorly Understood
Out Now by Oxford University Press.
So great to have you on today.
Oh, thanks, David.
Great to be with you.
So, I mean, let's just jump into maybe what's
one of the media diving boards into this topic,
maybe which which are the misunderstandings
about the poor in the United States, two of
which, correct me if I'm wrong, are the misunderstanding
that most poor people don't work and the misunderstanding
that most poor people are minorities, ethnically
or racially.
Tell us maybe how this came about, but also
the truth of the statistics.
Yeah, I think, you know, kind of underlying
those.
This is the idea that the myth that poverty
happens to somebody else, it doesn't happen
to me.
And so, you know, it happens to folks who
don't work or folks that are minorities, but
it doesn't really affect me.
It's not going to happen to me.
And what we show in the book is that actually,
if you look at the MAJAW, the majority of
folks in poverty are actually white.
A majority of more folks in poverty live in
suburban areas than in central cities.
And some of the deepest seated poverty is
in rural America.
And the idea that the poor don't work is simply
wrong.
Most of the poor have worked in the past.
It will work in the future.
And it's it's really important to think about
poverty is something that people go through.
They're not poor their whole lives.
They they hit a spell where they have some
tough times.
They experience poverty.
They may be out of work, but then they get
back on their feet and they will work in the
future.
So, you know, I think underlying those ideas
is this myth that poverty is something that
happens to somebody else and doesn't happen
to me.
There's a few different things I think would
be interesting to explore.
You mentioned suburban versus urban.
Is there how can we quantify and qualify the
difference between the rural and suburban
poverty versus the urban poverty, which maybe
is more the caricature of where the myths
come from?
Yeah.
So if you you know, it's certainly the case
that folks in inner city central city areas,
the poverty rates are higher than the overall
rate.
But there's many more folks now that live
outside of central cities.
And so in terms of the number of folks in
poverty, you know, again, it's higher in surrounding
urban areas as opposed to the central city.
And as I mentioned, if you look at some of
the most extreme poverty in the United States,
it's actually found in rural America.
So areas like Appalachia, the Deep South and
Mississippi Delta, American Indian reservations,
the central corridor of California, all of
those areas have really, really deep seated
poverty.
And that's kind of when we will have this
image of of who are the poor.
We often think about the poor as nonwhites
in inner city areas.
And it's not to discount that that poverty
exists there, of course, but poverty is much,
much wider.
The way I like to describe it is that the
reach of poverty is really wide, but its grip
is is not that strong.
People move in and out of poverty a lot.
What are the most common reasons that people
who at some point were not poor end up in
poverty, which maybe is different from transgenerational
poverty, where you're born into poverty and
remain there?
Is there an interesting distinction to be
made here?
There is.
So the folks that are long term in poverty
is about 10 to 15 percent of everybody who
will experience poverty so far.
Eighty five percent of people who experience
poverty do so for a fairly short period of
time.
And by short, I mean a year or two.
Now, why do they experience poverty?
It's because things happen to people that
they didn't anticipate, like losing a job,
a family splitting up, getting sick, a pandemic
occurring.
All of these things have the potential to
throw people into poverty for a short period,
a fairly short period of time.
Now, what's interesting about this is I've
done a lot of work and and the book focuses
on this right from the get go of the question
of what's the long term likelihood that an
American at some point will experience poverty.
Right.
It turns out that between the ages of 20 and
75, 60 percent of Americans will experience
one year below the official poverty line and
three quarters will experience poverty or
near poverty.
And the reason is because, again, over a long
period of time, things happen to people that
can throw them into poverty.
And when that happens, there's not a lot in
place to protect them.
How how much or is that number at all skewed
to people in their very early 20s in college
who are technically in poverty, but it's not
really reflective of their situation?
Yeah, that's a great that's a great question.
And that's a question that we often get on
that research.
And so what we did is we took out those folks
and did the analysis and found that it it
varied.
It didn't change very much.
I mean, the number of people that are actually
in graduate school that might sort of fit
that sort of starving student picture is actually
pretty small.
So it doesn't.
Really affect the numbers very much at all,
graduate school and presumably college juniors
and seniors, right?
I mean, 20, 20 years.
Yeah, it's so it's really it's not a huge
doesn't change the numbers dramatically.
It doesn't change that when you again, when
you look over a 30 or 40 year period, it really
doesn't change it very much when
it comes to the I mean, I it may go back before
this, actually.
Maybe that's a good good question for me.
Some of the big historical markers of when
the narrative around the poor started to resemble
what it is now.
I think back to the Reagan era, the story
of, you know, the welfare taking Cadillac
queen, having kids in order to get food stamps.
And how far back does that trope sort of go?
Well, I think you're right that the kind of
the modern version of that really started
with Ronald Reagan, but the idea of the deserving
and the undeserving poor actually goes back
400 years to sort of England's poor laws at
the time.
But certainly Ronald Reagan was the one in
more modern times that really emphasized that.
And the argument that he's make it was making
was using those stereotypes to argue for smaller
government.
You know, his big line, one of his lines was,
you know, government is not the the answer
government is the problem that we fought a
war on poverty and poverty won.
Well, it turns out that well constructed government
programs actually have a very significant
effect on reducing poverty.
So take the war on poverty in nineteen fifty
nine, the poverty rate in the United States
was around 22 percent.
By nineteen seventy three, it was 11 percent.
We cut poverty in half because of the war
on poverty and because of the strong economic
growth during that time.
So did we eliminate poverty?
No, but it's an example that government actually
can be quite effective in reducing poverty.
So in terms of reducing poverty, I mean, there
are some poverty inducing factors that are
similar around the world and there are some
that are that are less common, you know, medical
expense.
Bankruptcy doesn't exist in many countries.
It does exist in the United States.
So this understanding that this may be hard
to parse out when we talk about poverty, discussions
often include all of the following and more
minimum wage, access to health care, improving
education, cost of living, rising wage gap,
you on and on and on.
What interventions have been shown to be the
most effective at cutting poverty?
Well, I think the number one number one solution
is jobs that can pay a decent wage, jobs that
provide a livable wage and also having benefits
associated with those.
So what has happened in the United States
over the last 40 or 50 years is we've been
producing more and more low wage jobs in jobs
that don't provide benefits.
And so a median male worker who is full time
in the labor market today is earning slightly
less once you control for inflation than he
was earning in 1973.
There's been a huge stagnation, and that's
one of the reasons why more and more people
are at risk of poverty because they're working
at jobs that just can't support a family.
So I think that's the number one factor that
we need to focus on.
But as you point out, there are many other
factors as well, such as having access to
health care, child care, good education.
Those are all really key elements to addressing
the issue of poverty.
When we think about stimulus, like the kind
we've seen now three times during the course
of the pandemic, or a proposal for a 15 dollar
minimum wage, which the sort of more free
market minded folks would say these are these
are artificial decisions that are being imposed.
The minimum wage would be a price floor on
labor that might be above what the market
would dictate.
Or just dumping a one time payment on people
is not really going to systemically change
the value of their work to an employer or
whatever the case may be.
What do we know about the longer term impact
of those types of interventions?
Yeah, interesting.
So first of all, the idea of providing kind
of a monthly universal payment to families
with children has been going on in European
countries for decades.
And it's shown that that's really, really
effective in terms of reducing the rate of
childhood poverty.
And in the end, President Biden's pandemic
package, we have a version of that where every
family with a child would get three or four
hundred dollars a month.
So we are actually starting to get some research
in on the effect of this type of a of a policy.
There's a.
There was a study that just came out from
Stockton, California, that did kind of a universal
basic income and they actually showed it had
really positive effects.
And interestingly, it actually the folks that
were getting the UBI actually had higher rates
of employment than those who weren't, because
that's one of the fears that all of this creates
a work disincentive.
Actually, it creates a lot of positive incentives
in terms of people being able to live what
I often refer to as a livable life.
The mobility question is an interesting one,
where there's a bunch of ways to measure how
likely it is that if born into poverty, one
will exit poverty.
And you can look at this at a country level,
you can pass it out by education and race
and all of these different things for those
who are born into poverty.
But get out of it.
What do we know about the following generation,
the kids of those folks and their likelihood
of remaining out of poverty as well?
Yeah.
So the way I like to think about this is that
it's the notion of cumulative inequality.
So first of all, as I said, most folks who
experience poverty do so fairly short periods
of time, but they may not get that far above
the poverty line.
Yeah, but the way the way we we often like
to think about the United States is that there's
a level playing field and everybody's kind
of starting at the same point.
And I use the analogy in the book of actually
what's going on is a modified game of Monopoly.
Oh, this is interesting.
Now, I've used this I think I've used this
analogy before.
And I'm wondering where you first heard it,
actually.
Well, I thought I came up with it.
Oh.
Oh, that's interesting.
Wow.
I don't know.
Will tell it to us because let's see if it's
the same one I use.
Yeah.
OK, so we normally think of a game of Monopoly.
We have three players.
Everybody starts out with fifteen hundred
dollars.
Yeah.
They go around the rules of the game apply
and you know, luck and chance and skill determine
who is going to win the game.
But now let's look at an altered game of Monopoly
where player one starts out with five thousand
dollars.
Player two starts out with the fifteen hundred
dollars and player three starts out with two
hundred fifty dollars.
Now we're still going to have the same rules
and and abide by those.
But who's going to win most of those games?
Well, given the prior advantages, player one
is going to win considerably more even if
he or she is not as lucky or as skilled.
OK, and the other point is that player one
can play the game differently than player
three.
They can take more chances.
If player three makes one mistake, it's over.
And that's what's really going on in this
country, is we have an alternate game of Monopoly
where some players are starting out with that
five thousand dollars more and more players
are starting out with maybe a thousand or
fifteen hundred.
And unfortunately, many people are starting
out with the two hundred and fifty dollars.
So we really we need to think about how can
we address some of these prior advantages
and disadvantages so that we have more of
a sense of the quality of opportunity which
we often talk about as important in the United
States.
Right.
So we're at the end of our time.
But so my version of the analogy is, yeah,
it's almost the same.
It's everybody really does get the same amount
of cash.
But the late starting players have to contend
with all the properties already having hotels
on them.
Absolutely.
And so but it's really the same idea that's
very high.
Yeah.
No, that that
is we've been speaking with Mark Robert, Rank,
professor of social welfare at Washington
University in St. Louis.
The book is poorly understood, which we will
link to in the YouTube video for for our conversation
today.
Mark, really a pleasure having you on.
Oh, this was great, Dave and I really enjoyed
it.